die ecke 38 und chicago in minneapolis
seit einem jahr herrscht hier
ausnahmezustand seit dem gewaltsamen tod
von george freude an seinem ersten
todestag sind viele menschen gekommen um
ihm zu gedenken
sein name steht heute sinnbildlich für
amerikas kampf gegen rassismus
heute ist nicht der jahrestag des todes
von george wright vielmehr feiern wir
seien liegen
unsere gesellschaft ist auf dem
richtigen weg es gibt aber noch viel zu
tun haben
marias leben spielt sich fast nur noch
auf dem square ab wir haben sie in den
letzten wochen immer wieder begleitet
ihr alltag hat sich durch das was hier
passierte komplett geändert die frühere
lehrerin widmet sich ganz dem square
veranstaltet gesprächsrunden hält die
nachbarschaft zusammen
es ist eine gemeinschaft die auf steht
gegen systematische unterdrückung gegen
anti schwarz es ist eine gemeinschaft
die versteht dass diese vier blocks ein
experiment dafür sind eine gemeinde zu
schmieden
ohne auf die polizei als problemlöser
angewiesen zu sein
gemeinschaft steht über allem
zusammenhalten in einer welt in der sich
immer mehr menschen in ihre blasen
zurückziehen
der tod von george floyd hat auch
antonius leben verändert er kämpft für
eine polizeireform und widmet diesem
projekt seine ganze energie
die vision von öffentlicher sicherheit
für die wir uns stark machen soll für
alle leute gut sein
zurzeit haben wir ein system das nur für
manche gut funktioniert für jene die
nicht diese hautfarbe hatte 20.000
unterschriften haben sie gesammelt um
ihren vorschlag auf den weg zu bringen
genug für einen bürgerentscheid
sie wollen die präsenz von bewaffneten
polizisten auf den straßen reduzieren
wie eine neue behörde für öffentliche
sicherheit genau aussehen könnte
das sollen dann die bürger der stadt
selbst entscheiden unsere idee ist das
gesetz die bürger von minneapolis müssen
den rest liefern die sehnen die muskeln
das fett die nervenzellen und nerven
dieses neuen systems rückblick
fünfundzwanzigster mai 2020 aufnahmen
die amerika für immer verändern könnten
mehr als neun minuten lang presst
polizist derek schuh wenn das knie auf
george haushalts bis er stirbt
dafür wird er unter anderem wegen mordes
zweiten grades ohne tötungsvorsatz
verurteilt
ein weißer ex-polizist verantwortlich
für den tod eines schwarzen abgeführt in
handschellen ein bild das bei vielen
hoffnungen freisetzt die reaktion auf
dem square nach der verkündung vor gut
einem monat
sie reckten die fäuste gen himmel
schwarze weiße frauen männer groß und
klein einheit über äußerlichkeiten
hinweg zumindest für einen kurzen moment
denn alle hier wissen es ist nur ein
kleiner schritt
ich sehe natürlich auch das seit dem tod
von john lloyd bereits hunderte weitere
leute von der polizei getötet wurde
die mächtigen räumen niemals freiwillig
das feld
sie wollen nicht dass sich der status
quo ändert durch george hotz tod ist die
black lips matter bewegung größer
geworden monate der proteste zum teil
gewaltausbrüche verhaftungen brennende
straßenzüge im ganzen land und ein
präsident der stadt zu schlichten immer
weiter öl ins feuer goss der druck auf
veränderung wurde größer und kam auch in
washington an
so hat die neue administration ein nach
george floyd benanntes gesetz auf den
weg gebracht
es soll unter anderem die immunität von
polizistinnen und polizisten
einschränken und würgegriff verbieten
eine bundesweite polizeireform also die
aber bisher am widerstand der
republikaner gescheitert
für antonio sind diese politischen
widerstände er beleg dafür dass er und
die anderen aktivisten tatsächlich etwas
bewirkt wir müssen auf allen leveln
angreifen und kämpfen
der unterschied zwischen denen da oben
und uns hier unten ist dass wir die
konsequenzen schlechter politik jeden
tag zu spüren bekommen
john war lange aktiv ist jetzt hat ihn
die bewegung ins repräsentantenhaus von
minister gewählt
seitdem sein bester freund von der
polizei erschossen wurde versuchte er
sich immer wieder gehör zu verschaffen
[Musik]
dann starb george freut es folgte die
protestbewegung plötzlich war sein kampf
der kampf um millionen unmöglich zu
ignorieren
jetzt sitzt schon mit am tisch der
entscheider
er hat gleich mehrere gesetze entworfen
die unter anderem das ziel haben
bildungschancen von schwarzen zu erhöhen
[Musik]
es geht darum das problem an der wurzel
zu packen und die fäulnis mit
auszurotten
es ist wie eine zwiebel zu stehen
schicht um schicht und irgendwann
brauchen wir keine ordnungskräfte mehr
weil die menschen arbeit haben und geld
verdient und das der gemeinschaft gut
geht
daran glauben auch viele die in gedenken
an george kreuzung square gekommen sind
ein jahr nachdem der mann starb der ihm
seinen namen leiht amerika steht noch
vor einem langen weg im kampf gegen
rassismus
zumindest scheint es so als sei das land
ein paar schritte weiter gekommen
[Musik]